have to understand that these people
over there wake up every single day
trying to plan another 911 is it is that
is what they do and we've already it's
just such complete idiocy it's just hard
to believe why on Western values but why
is it that they're dedicating their
entire life to try to take down America
if anything I think the Muslims love the
West
far too much certainly the core we are
infidels at its core there is they there
well these empty slogans are the most
stupid things you could ever imagine if
you just stop to think about them Salam
aleikum greenies a peace how you doing
welcome to the Deen show we got an
exciting episode here with no strangers
to the show how are you we got professor
dr. Kevin Barret how are you I'm doing
very well have you been I've been great
that's really you know waging the truth
jihad is very rewarding
it's spiritually at least if not
financially and you said a word now
there's some people out there just
shaken you said you had I said truth
jihad jihad fees that be a lot so jihad
many people we were we talked about this
often that people have this miss notion
that jihad means a holy war which
actually you're struggling and striving
you know to get the truth out yeah the
greater jihad is the struggle to be a
better person the lesser jihad is the
struggle to defend your community best
way to defend the community today is
through the truth not through military
means we Muslims are overmatched most
places militarily and we have the truth
on our side so the truth is our best
weapon that's the best jihad now I
thought who better to have on the
program than someone who has practices
free speech at one time you're still
doing that what is is given to every
American here and you actually utilized
your free speech as a professor and you
got some trouble for that yeah well it
was also academic freedom that's what
the Academy is for is it's in the
secular world which has its problems but
it also has developed some good
institutions universities are supposed
to be about analyzing how things really
work and seeking the truth including
the truth about how power works in this
society so that's what I thought I was
doing and I thought it was what the
university was supposed to be doing but
apparently some higher-up political
people did not agree mm-hmm so you got
some trouble for that huh yeah there was
a bit of a witch hunt there at the
University of Wisconsin in 2006 state
legislators were calling for me to be
fired from the University and I fought
back so I spent about six months in the
media limelight that was my 15 minutes
of fame that just went on and on I'm
kind of glad that's over actually
because I'd rather be on your show than
on Sean Hannity's so I thought what
better person to to talk to bring on to
talk about you know Joe Rogan he he
recently had Dan Crenshaw on his program
and he we're gonna go ahead and play
this video Joe Rogan he's really toned
it down as far as spreading this hate
about Islam and Muslims
he was really we did some programs
specifically geared towards addressing
some of the some of the blunders that he
made regarding many of the false
accusations towards Islam so we
systematically one-by-one we went over
though all those you know provided the
evidence and he and he's kind of you
know we give him for the props and
respect he's kind of really toned it
down so this is not really much to do
with that but this is actually to do
with another topic that's intertwined
and connected to to what we'll be
discussing so I thought since you have a
lot of experience with a lot of these
things he's going to be discussing
you'll be a great person to go ahead and
react to some of these things that we're
gonna hear Dan Crenshaw say on the Joe
Rogan show how's that sound
sounds good okay let's let it rip well
most things I would say one of the one
thing she's quite outspoken about is is
our involvement overseas she's she would
generally she's much more of an
isolationist than I am what I remind
people when we're talking about that
particular subject why why do we keep
troops in Syria why do we keep troops in
Iraq why do we keep troops in
Afghanistan isn't the war over why don't
we bring the boys back home and the
answer is this is not a convention
war this is not something where you sign
a peace treaty with a uniformed army it
is it is a different it's a different
situation we send guys like me over
there so that they don't come here we
send guys like me over there so that we
keep pressure on them and prevent them
for whom the operational space and
timing to committed another 9/11 you
have to understand that these people
over there
wake up every single day trying to plan
another 9/11 is it is that is what they
do and we've already I can hear you're
ready to speak okay so remember all
right so he said these people he's
referring to Muslims yeah obviously yeah
so they are just waiting for another
opportunity to strike it's just such
complete idiocy it's just hard to
believe that anybody who's paying any
attention at all much less is actually a
congressperson could believe this
nonsense I mean come on you know and
this this takes us right back to the
whole notion of 9/11 itself which we
were told originally was all about they
hate our freedoms and then the wars were
launched on this idea we have to go over
there so they won't fight us here well
these empty slogans are the most stupid
things you could ever imagine if you
just stop to think about them the you
know the first-level
why why would anybody hate our freedoms
that's crazy
the you know the the second at the
second level is that Joe Rogan is Iraq
not Joe Rogan but Dan Crenshaw he was
saying that these Muslims in places like
Syria Iraq and Afghanistan are all
dreaming of 9/11 the idea so we have to
go over and fight the Muslims wait a
minute who are we actually supporting in
these places in Syria the u.s. created
and sustained isis or daesh
in in iraq even more so in iraq there
was a strategy by which the u.s. was
able to try to try to stay in iraq by
arming different factions to fight each
other and so the u.s. created daesh isis
in iraq and over in afghanistan is the
same thing in order to try to defeat the
Taliban or at least make it impossible
for the insurgency to fully win
they brought their dire scenaries over
to Afghanistan so in fact the very
so-called extremist Muslims that were
supposedly fighting over there actually
are created and sustained by the US and
that's part of a larger program to
destabilize the Islamic world and what
is this all about well it's about two
things oil and Israel not necessarily in
that order the major thrust of this war
on Islam is primarily about trying to
keep the State of Israel expanding and
more powerful than its neighbors that's
what we were told before 9/11 that's
what we were basically told after 9/11
by General Clark when he said the real
purpose of 9/11 was to take out seven
countries in five years who was that
that was General Wesley Clark he said
that after 9/11 one of the neo cons came
running up to him and and said you know
we're going to be going into Iraq he's
what does he have to do with 9/11 and
then a little later the same actually
this was a sort of messenger from the
neo cons who came back and said it's
actually worse than that he said we're
gonna take out seven countries in five
years and he named those countries and
with a few possible exceptions like
Somalia they were all the countries that
were causing problems for Israel and
many of us now view 9/11 is essentially
a coup d'etat by hardline
neoconservative Zionists allied with the
like who'd faction in Israel and there's
all sorts of evidence to support that
and these wars have actually been about
manipulating a so called Islamic
extremism at creating mercenary forces
of so-called Islamic extremists such as
as Die eesh in order to destabilize
these countries that's what's really
going on there tulsi gabbard knows this
and then Crenshaw is pretending not to
know this I can't believe he's that
ignorant that's what I was gonna ask is
he dumb or is he playing dumb that's a
great question and sometimes it's hard
to tell you know there's a famous
Israeli leader who once told the BBC
correspondent
hard the problem with us is that we
believe I run propaganda and people who
were brainwashed by 9/11 and so many
were have a tendency to cling to the
emotions that they felt that day that
have stayed with them they have so they
bought into this myth of defending
civilization against these horrible
barbaric savages who supposedly killed
all these people by blowing up buildings
with planes and that that myth and that
trauma this is really a kind of a
trauma-based mind control or you know
post-traumatic stress leading to
embracing a totally irrational worldview
and a lot of people volunteered to serve
in the military based on that and maybe
Dan Crenshaw was one of them but then
they go over there and they experience
the horror of these wars and many of
them experience the truth and realize oh
my goodness we are invaders who are here
to destabilize and wreak havoc in these
societies this isn't a noble fight at
all were the aggressors were the
invaders and a lot of these people then
don't discover the truth about 9/11 and
like the guys who made loose loose
change those guys were veterans and they
realized you know the the what was that
what was that called loot loose change
those were veteran Army veterans oh yeah
yeah yeah Dylan Avery and I the other
guys were had served in Iraq and they
came back I think while they were in
Iraq they actually discovered that 9/11
was a false flag operation they came
back and made that film without it and
it went viral I've got millions of views
yeah what what what I take strong
exception to is that when you when you
say they and you're saying Muslims like
there you have nothing better to do and
this this whole myth you know like they
hate our way of life you know these
people are in another part of the world
you know minding their own business if
you look at before Iraq before
Afghanistan go back I mean you feel if
you look there there there wasn't this
hostility I mean if you look at other
countries you know that there there
wasn't a war with how were these other
countries were they getting attacked you
know from from from whoever was there it
was their peace and with all these other
countries why coincidentally where you
have for instance you have Iraq that was
invaded and based on a lie this is just
a fact right it was based on saying that
there was weapons of mass destruction
which there wasn't so it was invaded
based on a lie you also have Afghanistan
how many 2 million people minimum killed
how many say well you know it there are
different estimates at the minimum in
that the total number of people killed
in these 911 wars is 4 or 5 million
horrified in the maximum estimate that's
been put out by a respectable scientist
is 27 million killed 32 million erased
from from the world because 5 million
children would have been born if these
parents hadn't been yeah so yeah 20 it's
a 27 million Muslim Holocaust according
to dr. Gideon Polya who's a Jewish
professor in Australia this is a Jewish
person who's putting these numbers I
went actually very low 2 million but now
you're talking about 20 again and that's
to all of the 9/11 Wars that's not just
Afghanistan is not just that's all of
these wars that were based off you know
9/11 right that opened the door it was a
catalyst and now prompted going into all
of these different lands right so ok so
that's my point
as if Muslims are just violent and they
just want to fight and they want to come
over here and they want to invade yeah
it's it's crazy you know
the thing is they've they had to
traumatize Americans to make them
innocent enough to you know put it to
make them childlike enough to believe
this ridiculous myth this lie that you
know they hate our freedoms they did not
know you know if you're rational you
know that all military activity is
basically rational some people make
mistakes when they choose to do this or
that in the military fight but it's it's
all based on strategy and tactics now
ask yourself what any Vietnamese fighter
think that blowing up skyscrapers in New
York it's let's say in 1970 would
somehow help their cause and cause the
Americans to leave of course not the
Vietnamese knew that the way to make the
Americans leave was to give them a
bloody nose in Vietnam and in if they'd
been stupid enough to come over and blow
up skyscrapers in New York Nixon would
have had a perfect excuse to nuke them
and likewise yeah the idea that Muslims
yeah an anti-imperialist most
and there are good reasons to be an
anti-imperialist Muslim to say that you
know the United States needs to
radically change its policy needs to
stop you know putting these military
bases all over the world eight hundred
military bases occupying most of the
world including most of the Islamic
world the US needs to pack up and defend
its own borders and go home that's
that's a reasonable position and
likewise that the State of Israel needs
to completely rethink itself and become
a state for all its people not just a
Jewish supremacist expansion this
genocidal State although that's
reasonable and so it's reasonable be an
anti imperialist
anti Zionist Muslim that's what I am but
would we really be stupid enough to
think that blowing up buildings in New
York would help our cause and would make
the Americans and the Zionists leave
it's the opposite of obvious as a PR
nightmare so it's like who benefits
that's exactly who benefits from that so
that was point number number one I mean
just someone to naively just believe
something like people over there who are
eating real food who are just you know
with their family minding their own
business some don't even have TV and I
watch the news don't even know about
what's going on in America they don't
care but now to assume that these people
are just like everybody in their home
they just can't wait to get over here
with their fangs and just attack and
that's just nonsensical so that's one
second point is what about all the other
countries that are out there they don't
have problems with Muslims they don't
they're not invading Muslim lands what
about those countries out there because
that would also destroy this argument
what about them that they also have the
same Western lifestyle that they are
assuming that Muslims hate yeah like why
would Muslims hate the western lifestyle
the truth is unfortunately that many
Muslims have let go of their own
traditions and their own religious
worldview and want nothing more than the
you know the good material things that
the West can give them if anything I
think the Muslims love the West
far too much certainly that's a good
point they love if there was far too
much yeah yeah it's a you know Muslims
who love the West too much maybe that
could be a self-help group or something
yeah it's seriously though the the
Muslim world
let's take Afghanistan Dan Crenshaw is
talking about Afghanistan if we're not
over there massacring people in
Afghanistan
they're gonna plot some new 911 well
guess what there's a poll that was taken
in Afghanistan asking what the people of
Afghanistan thought about 9/11 and I
think it was like 95 plus percent of
them said what's 9/11 they hadn't even
heard of it yeah that's I'm talking
inaudibly every single Muslim in
Afghanistan has never even heard of 9/11
yeah so Peter said I mean people are in
there at their farms and their caves you
know out there just taking care of their
family and then like dirty wars you've
seen that documentary like dirty wars
yeah and then you have this drug yeah
and then I mean their mind their own
business they got a wedding a next to
you know a drone strike or you know you
have people coming in and just kill the
whole village I mean then you're
creating you're creating these enemies
right in other places like Pakistan
where they have heard about 9/11 because
Pakistan is english-speaking and plugged
in to the international world more than
Afghanistan is another poll showed that
97% of Pakistanis disagree with the
official story of 9/11 that is only 3%
of Pakistanis believe that Osama bin
Laden and al-qaeda do that a little bit
and of course they're right because they
know what al-qaeda is over there
Pakistan actually is more aware movie
after the people in Afghanistan didn't
you know even though bin Laden was there
most of the people there didn't know
anything about him and Pakistan people
are a little more aware of all these
things and they understand that this was
a neoconservative coup d'etat that one
of the top Afghan generals Hamid Gul
who is it was a colleague of mine at
Veterans today.com came out just a few
days after 9/11 and said this was
obviously a coup d'etat within the
United States it has nothing to do with
al-qaeda and no other top-level
commentators from around the Islamic
world have said similar things Mohammed
Haeckel greatest you know modern
historian in Egypt who was high up in
the Egyptian government said you know
when I was up in the Egyptian government
we were infiltrating al-qaeda and so was
everybody else the Americans the Saudis
the Israelis everybody invitation
infiltrated al-qaeda you know they
couldn't flush the toilet without half
the intelligence agencies enter of
hearing it so al-qaeda was basically a
cat's paw for intelligence agencies was
founded by the CIA and their Saudi
friends
and it never had any independence and so
this whole thing was a big setup yeah
and I just think as one who is following
Islam Islam simply submitting your will
to the Creator trying to be a better
human being each and every day I think
about so many prophetic statements from
the last final measure problem Mohamed
where one of them comes to mind where he
said worship the all-mighty the most
merciful and spread peace we wish each
other when we saw each other peace be
with you now what kind of people who are
you know commanded to spread peace are
gonna be out there you know spreading
this kind of like violence that this man
is trying to equate with they them out
there they're just like that that's
their you know mission in life to get
over here and destroy life over here
that's just not sensible it doesn't make
any sense that's right but you could
understand why Iraqis or people in
Afghanistan might believe that about the
United States because that's what they
see you know they just see their
countries being decimated and millions
of people being murdered by these
invaders from across the sense but
fortunately for Americans almost
everybody in the Muslim world can make
the distinction between the American
government which is brainwashing its
people with lies like the kind of lies
this one I Dajjal Crenshaw is telling
people Wow wanna live you know you know
they want this image of the one-eyed the
job Dajjal is the Antichrist and this
you know many people like Muhammad Assad
and Sheikh Imran Hosein
and others interpret that as meaning
that the Dajjal Antichrist will be
seeing with only the eye of sort of the
superficial aspect of things the
material aspect of things and they won't
won't see into the deeper level right he
talked about the deeper look but he's
the one who's not seeing into the deeper
level just like the Dajjal the Dajjal
can not see the spiritual nature of
things and can't see beneath the surface
of things and this guy needs to you know
to take off his eyepatch and get that
other eye fixed so he can see with two
eyes and have depth perception and seen
the deeper level of what's really going
on here which is of course that he's
been taken in by a huge hoax that's why
I ask is he really playing dumb or is he
dumb I mean I don't I don't want to
disrespect anybody but you know just
let's just continue on see what other
things that he has to say
Iker as a person we just disagree
things but there's a respect there to
play devil's advocate some would say
that the reason why they want a plat
plot another 9/11 is because we're over
there yeah I disagree with that so let's
let's look at the Asama bin Laden
example what exactly did we do to this
guy you know what will helped him right
yeah exactly Soviets with the Mujahideen
exactly in the he was a Magi Deen
fighter we helped him fight the Soviets
we protected Saudi Arabia from invasion
from Saddam Hussein that's his homeland
and yet he hated us and when we left we
never occupied Saudi Arabia we left when
they asked us to leave after we defended
them and prevented another invasion from
Saddam Hussein after he invaded Kuwait
what is it we did to make this guy so
mad and the answer is we didn't do
anything objectively speaking he hates
us because of our Western ideology he
hates us because he hates us and and
it's hard for us to understand because
it's not logical but it is the truth and
it's it's so that's an it's a prime
example of why we with this this this is
a long-term fight and it's it's not
likely to go away anytime soon and that
the last thing I would say the world is
a very small place we can when we
pretend that we to ignore things going
on in the Middle East we can pretend
that they won't come here but the
reality is that's a 12-hour flight and
and the speed of information travels
even faster you know when we were seeing
a lot of attacks in the US and in Europe
when Isis was at its peak as its that's
its peak strength that was because they
were able to radicalize online notice
that they've stopped having that power
and it's because we actually took the
fight to them well there there certainly
are some conflicts between Wow a minute
he admitted he made it he said he
admitted that this is not it's not
logical what he's saying yeah yeah it's
not logical these Muslims are completely
crazed and illogical and they're just
trying to kill us for no reason even if
it's bad for their cause let's try to
get back to reality here dan who is
Osama bin Laden he was recruited by the
CIA to fight for the Americans in
Afghanistan where was he before 9/11 in
the summer of July of 2001 he
being treated for kidney disease at the
American Hospital in Dubai by an
American physician dr. Terry Calaway he
had terminal kidney disease at that time
on 9/11 itself he was in a military
hospital in Pakistan guarded by
Americans as well as Pakistanis that's
where he was he was under American
protection on 9/11 so the notion that
Osama bin Laden hates America is
ridiculous he was an American
collaborator or asset of some kind we
don't know to what extent he may have
been sincere in some of his statements
about rejecting American imperialism and
Zionism I hope he was sincere I'm
sincere about those same feelings and so
are most other informed people but he
certainly was an American asset and it
probably goes way beyond what I've just
said that that's just enough to kind of
get you started go back and do your
research go to the complete 9/11
timeline which archived references to
all of these news stories from 2001
you'll see bin Laden treated in the
American Hospital in Dubai reported by
the mainstream press never seriously
disputed and you'll find credible
reports about him being in that military
hospital in Pakistan with Americans as
well as Pakistanis guarding him on 9/11
itself now you also had a lot of many
many of the top Muslim clerics and
scholars there were they were warning
coming out I mean if people are trying
to say okay that Muslims support people
like you know people who would some
extreme ideas you had Muslim scholars
believe bin baz he was like the main
Mufti of Saudi Arabia he was and others
main scholars they were warning people
about about him you know about this
right absolutely and and isis or daesh
has been rejected even more unanimously
by the global muslim ummah there's
virtually nobody in the global Muslim
Ummah who takes them seriously they're
obviously a fossil even al-qaeda I mean
there there are some people who believe
that al-qaeda was real and I forget the
name of one of them was arrested in
Egypt I think in
there's a wonderful interview with him
where he talks about how everybody knows
that aisha isis was created by the
americans that and the evidence for that
is pretty much overwhelming there were
leaked wiki leak documents showing that
the u.s. wanted to create a
quote-unquote but they call it a not at
not as sunny but i think they call it a
jihadist or some of the jihadist
caliphate in syria and iraq and this
this was a year before isis was created
abu bakr al baghdadi who's created who's
supposedly the the founder of isis spent
four years possibly close to five years
in US custody in iraq i think people can
check this up well the official american
stories i never heard this you know the
american stories he was only in custody
for a year part of that time i've
arrived and part of the time at Bagram
but then it turns out that there are
witnesses were there at Bagram who say
he was in there for over four years and
he had the complete run of the
facilities could do anything he wanted
and spent his time organizing what later
became isis or daesh and the official
story about that you know they'd say
okay the official stories it was only
one year but the official story admits
that during that year he had the run of
the facilities could do anything he
wanted and spent his time organizing and
creating - that's the official
mainstream story so either way you look
at it - was created under the noses of
the Americans at camp Bagram and if you
dig a little deeper you'll see that it
took them four years to do it not just
one year and that al-baghdadi is even
more of an obvious total 100% American
agent than bin Laden was you've heard
about half a billion that was spent by a
UK PR firm this is known facts that came
out not too long ago the fake terrorist
videos yeah right that's right there and
and that's probably just the tip of the
iceberg you've heard of them yeah the
reason I bring that up is because now
that that's come out so now if someone
will lie to you here and make fake stuff
here why wouldn't they make fake things
in
and in other areas well they have
they've been exposed making fake videos
left right and center many of the so
called Isis or diced videos have been
proven to be fakes yeah yeah and among
the bin Laden videos the most famous one
was produced in December of 2001 at that
time remember Bush had said we we know
bin Laden did it we don't need any
evidence but the world wasn't accepting
that and suddenly miraculously this
videotape appeared discovered by
allegedly by some anonymous soldier in
Afghanistan which shows some guy who
looks sort of like bin Laden except he's
a lot fatter has a different face uses a
different hand and wears fancy jewelry
this guy is saying you know we knew that
the towers we're gonna you know be
damaged we didn't realize they were all
gonna fall down or something like that's
it so you could take it as an indirect
supposed confession well the so-called
Fatih bin Laden video is blatantly fake
and I invited America's top bin Laden
specialist dr. Bruce Lawrence of Duke
University on my radio show and I asked
him this who is it who is this professor
and dr. Bruce Lawrence he's yeah he'd
written a book called I think messages
to the world about bin Laden he was at
one of the top bin Laden's specialists
so you brought on the specialist now man
I'm on my show and and I said you know
what about this Fatih bin Laden video
does anybody really believe that and he
said it's fake
he said it's bogus he said and I said
not only do I know it's bogus he says I
I am in close contact with the top
people on the get bin Laden units in the
alphabet agencies and they all know it's
bogus this man say his name again
his name is dr. Bruce Lawrence why
hasn't this been showcased on like Fox
News and CNN and the mainstream media
that's a very good question it's
certainly been footnoted in dr. David
Ray Griffin books about 9/11 and it's
been archived in various other places
but the mainstream won't touch it
and I asked Bruce Lawrence then I said
well why aren't wearing all you guys
speaking out and saying that the
so-called confession video is bogus and
he said you know he said it's very
convenient in some quarters to have
people believe that bin Laden did 9/11
because if we question that the other
possibilities are too horrible yeah well
somewhere what if someone says well what
are you defending I've been
bin Laden fan what would you say what I
would say is that you know I can't
really judge who bin Laden was and why
he did what he did but I'm pretty sure
he was a CIA asset and I don't really
approve of that and as far as his
feelings about 9/11 he's on the record
deploring 9/11 and saying this was
unacceptable 2001 right after it
happened bin Laden yeah gave interviews
with Pakistani newspapers and he was
quoted as saying that 9/11 was done by
people in the United States with their
own agenda he hinted that it was the
Zionists and he said that this was
unethical innocent women and children
and he deplored 9/11 and that was the
last we ever heard from the real bin
Laden because everything since then has
either been proven bogus not only that
Fadi bin Laden confession video has been
proven bogus but most of the other
so-called bin Laden videos are equally
obviously bogus there are a couple of
audios tapes that we can't prove are
bogus but since almost all of them yes
if there's so many that we can improve
our bogus somebody's putting somebody
put out lots and lots of bogus bin Laden
videos after the fall of 2001 and the
reasonable assumption is that they're
all bogus let's continue on and see what
I'll stay Joe and Dan have to say well
there there certainly are some conflicts
between their ideology and Western
ideology but why on Western values but
why is it that they're dedicating their
entire life to try to take down America
well I mean this is always the question
it is a question it's and it's you
almost have to ask them exactly why
right but I mean at its core we are
infidels at its core there's they
they're they're taking an extreme view
of Islamic fundamentalism and believing
that we were infidels that must be
destroyed I mean okay so he answered it
so I like what okay Joel started he's
gonna play devil's out of the kit and
and he's the one kind of pushing it like
that doesn't really make sense he's
coming up and pretty much questioning
what he's saying so now he's saying we
got to ask them so we're here that were
them were the Muslims right but we're
not extremists as its
doesn't call us to be extreme maybe
extremely kind and merciful towards the
creation but now the point is that he's
it's because his answer is because
they're infidels which actually is
that's a Christian term isn't it that's
a per day terrible the you know the only
the term that they pretend that they're
translating is is kaffir
but that comes from kufur at which its
root meaning is ingratitude and so what
it really gets down to is cooler is that
being ungrateful for the beautiful
creation that God or Allah has given us
and it can be ingratitude when the
Prophet comes with the truth and turning
away from that and rejecting it and
lying about it that's another form of
ingratitude so that's what the term
means but it certainly is not a blanket
term to disparage all non-muslims or non
nominal Muslims you know we Muslims
understand that the message of the Quran
is something that in its universal and
that the human nature is universal - we
have a v Roth which is basically good
and so that people are born as something
else our number one they may very well
come to Islam as we understand it and
number two they are quite capable of
being good people within their own
traditions that's why whenever Islam is
in power
it protects religious minorities unlike
Christianity which it has a very bad
history of trying to force everybody to
convert to Christianity Islam
traditionally has not done that and
we're now talking about the ideal Islam
which I about real-world Islam that even
in real world Islam with power-hungry it
potentates you know not really obeying
us along the way they should they still
have a pretty good record of protecting
religious minorities so this notion of
oh we just attacking and making were
killing all the you know the cool fire
and all of that that's that's insanity
and you know maybe there are you know
point 1 percent of Muslims get
brainwashed and believe that kind of
insanity but it's mostly people like
this guy Crenshaw who are making up a
big lie it's like a blood libel and Jews
talk about blood libels when they say
that Jews roast and eat Christian babies
well this is a blood libel against
Muslims the idea that Muslims want to go
out and kill everybody else look
at the real-world go visit a Muslim
country hang out with Muslims and you
quickly find out that that's not the
case that goes back to what I was saying
if you look at the history for hundreds
of hundreds of years we didn't have all
all of this but all these wars and all
this drama and everything you know there
was there was some peace and simple
accessibility but now when when when all
these Wars start you know the average
person wants peace
alright Muslims want peace they want to
live in peace with their neighbors they
want to live in peace first and foremost
with their Creator with their families
so they're painting out Muslims to be
these violent extremists and now they're
the others so it's easier to go ahead
and invade them kill them but then what
about people say the people who don't
there are some one would say well who
wouldn't want peace but the people that
then won't earn a profit when there is
peace absolutely and that's what this
really boils down to you know there's a
big lie out there saying that all the
wars are created by religion and that's
not true wars are mainly about struggles
for resources and power material power
and it's the power-hungry greedy people
who are driving wars in all cultures
that includes the Muslim cultures you
know we haven't always had good
leadership Betty in the most look at
Muslim history there been a lot of
blood-soaked dictators running Muslim
communities and getting away with it too
you know we haven't been perfect but
let's not blame that on the religion you
look at the Christian world there have
been all sorts of blood-soaked dictators
and kings and potentates in the
Christian world they don't follow
Christianity they're greedy for power
and money
that's where war comes from and so today
who's profiting from war it isn't really
the Muslim countries it's the people
selling the weapons to the Muslim
countries and look at Trump and his
friends at General Dynamics selling huge
piles of weapons to the Saudis who are
then massacring the people of Yemen and
what amounts to a genocide this is all
being driven by money and power the
Saudi leadership wants to get money and
power by taking over influence in Yemen
the American leadership wants to sell
all these weapons and make lots of money
that's where this is all coming from and
not what did 9/11 do it doubled the US
military budget and people made billions
and billions of dollars off of that
that's what this is really about so
those would those would be the people
who wouldn't want peace are the people
who profit during war
whereas big business absolutely that's
that's the bottom line of war war is a
racket as General Smedley Butler
brilliantly put it you know he's one of
mine war is a racket war is a racket
that's the name of General Smedley
Butler is great book he's a true
American Hero he he's a whistleblower a
Marine Corps general who told the truth
about the real nature of war there is a
another professor here I want to get
your take on what he had to say his name
is David Ray Griffin he said pretty much
all the evidence that America was
attacked by Muslims on 9/11 when subject
to critical scrutiny appears to have
been fabricated that's who is whose
David this is an academic there's a
professor emeritus you know someone who
also now is coming out putting his
career on the line and everything to
speak to say this to defend Muslims
David Ray Griffin has written I believe
about 15 books on 9/11 he is the
greatest scholar on the subject of 9/11
in any country and he is the co-founder
of the process school of Christian
theology which is the most advanced and
respected school of Christian theology
it's the only one that secular
intellectuals really take seriously he
and John Cobb found at that school so
these guys are the greatest Christian
theologians of our time he's Christian
also now yeah yeah
Protestant he's taught at Claremont he's
retired now and he and John Cobb have
both been very outspoken in pointing out
that obviously Muslims didn't do 9/11
obviously all of this was fabricated the
official story of 9/11 is a complete
joke you know the 9/11 Commission for
example said that have all of these
so-called hijacker pilots who we know by
the way we're not even on the planes the
the best pilot was a guy named Hani
Hanjour who supposedly flew an amazing
stunt flight into the Pentagon while
Hani Hanjour was such a bad pilot that
he couldn't even be allowed to solo in a
Cessna training aircraft and yet the
official story has him taking over the
controls of a 757 at 30,000 feet over
Ohio turning it around making a beeline
for Washington DC flying over the
Pentagon for no reason if you were if
you were gonna hit the Pentagon in that
situation you just dive into it but now
he goes over the Pentagon
and then does a corkscrew dive dropping
more than you know 8,000 feet in two
minutes which is enough to pull g-forces
to knock everybody out on the plane and
then come straight down to the ground
and then level out along the ground and
hit the newly reinforced and largely
empty part of the Pentagon killing only
the accountants who and and some Office
of Naval Intelligence guys and the
accountants were I'm hot on the trail of
the 2.3 trillion dollars missing from
the Pentagon and guess what
Rumsfeld announced that two point three
trillion dollars was missing from the
Pentagon he announced it the night
before on September 10th 2001 this
official story is insane a guy who can't
fly does the least possible damage to
the Pentagon by taking out the
accountants who are looking for two
point three trillion dollars seven times
the military but annual military budget
which disappeared seven times the annual
military budget disappeared the night
before 9/11 and as announced by Rumsfeld
I mean this official story is is is just
beyond belief I can't it's still
shocking to me that there's anybody who
even accepts it now people hearing this
for the first time I mean you get kind
of nervous to talk about this because
right away people start to associate you
with being you know they putting labels
on you and now someone might say well
you're just a conspiracy theorist sure
you know making this stuff up there's an
official story there was a committee you
know of intellectual scientists whoever
the case and this is this is what they
confirmed and now you're come who are
you to come question this well you know
there hasn't really been any significant
group of experts of any kind who have
confirmed this official story they
they're you know there's there was the
nist group that looked at what happened
to these three skyscrapers and the
entire World Trade Center every building
in the World Trade Center was totaled
and destroyed most notably the three
skyscrapers that are blown up in obvious
controlled demolitions but the other
buildings were blown up too with
explosives huge you know the giant
crater took it just blew away most of
building three and building five
likewise blown up anyway the the people
tasked with explaining this officially
four
government we're all on the government's
payroll and they still had a terrible
time coming up with any way to explain
that but the 9/11 Commission report
which is the official story of the whole
event doesn't even mention building
seven
the most obvious Achilles heel in the
official they don't mention it even
mention it
there's nothing zero what what about
this new study from the University of
Alaska that was I believe it was a three
hundred thousand dollar study what did
they conclude that's led by dr. Halsey
of the University of Alaska and Ali's
why is he hosting a study if there's an
official report what would motivate this
I mean how would how would a University
of Alaska go ahead and get funding to do
a study like this why would they be
doing it I think they might have had to
get some independent funding to do with
as I recall this is an independent study
yeah these are the more than ones that
you can you assume you can trust if it's
independent certainly and that's been
the problem is that the official stuff
has all come from people on the payroll
of the US government yeah dr. Halsey of
University of Alaska and his colleagues
of course looked at building seven
before they when they were first
conceiving of having to look into this
more closely and said this is ridiculous
I mean this is if we actually talk to
these guys and there are many thousands
of architects and engineers who've
signed on at architects and engineers
for 9/11 truth and if you actually talk
to these people you know they're not as
careful as they are in their written
work and so on they try to be very
professional if you sit down and talk
with them they will just you know tell
you how absurd this official story is
how obvious it is that not just building
seven which is the one that the
untrained eye can see is a controlled
demolition but the towers as well are
being blown up that they these buildings
couldn't possibly just fall down for
random causes as the official story
indicates so what would be the motive of
someone like this coming out from this
university this this is a professor
another yeah there are thousands of
people like this now yeah if you go to
architects and engineers for 9/11 truth
you'll see more than 2,000 architects
and engineers who've risked their life
there well I don't think they risk their
lives but they're certainly risking the
reputations to tell the truth and
they're doing it out of their hearts
they're doing jihad yeah they're they're
doing the truth jihad - yeah most of
or not muslims if you are struggling
striving to get what they believe is the
truth to get it out what did this this
study confirm at the end again
well dr. Halsey study from University
Laska I believe is showing in great
detail why building 7 had to be a
controlled demolition most people don't
know that building seven it wasn't hit
by a plane that's right and it fell down
at 5:20 in the afternoon see the other
the big built most of the World Trade
Center was destroyed in the bombings
around 9:00 in the morning ninth it's
actually closer to 10:00 in the morning
but building seven just fell down for no
apparent reason at 5:20 in the afternoon
after a countdown to demolition went out
over police radio after the commercial
radio station had actually announced
that it was going to be taken down a
crowd gathered around building seven to
watch it come down and then a police
pushed people back forced them away from
the building saying that buildings about
to come down you can see the videos of
this and then a police radio countdown
went out ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one and at zero the
building just goes straight down into
the earth as if it were sort of an
elevator going into the earth a classic
controlled demolition what's that top
European demolition expert yeah danny
jowenko a lawyer humm who was the top
expert in europe on demolitions and he
was shown building seven by a dutch
media company or some some journalists
and they looked at this and he said well
this is obviously a controlled
demolition this is one of the greatest
controlled demolitions i've ever seen
very professional perfectly done and
they said you know this happened on 9/11
and he said oh really yeah he was
shocked
well I forget how long thereafter maybe
I think it was months or a year or
something after that he died in a very
strange car crash so there's also the
top demolition expert in the UK who has
stated the same thing but off the record
to Alan Hart the former lead BBC
correspondent for the Middle East and he
Alan Hart came on my radio show almost
ten years ago to break the news that the
top British demolition ex
it also said that these were obvious
demolitions and Alan Hart himself said
that of course 9/11 was a coup d'etat
and Alan believed that the Israelis were
behind it is it true that there's a new
poll that shows that more and more and
more Americans are questioning the
official story and they're also wanting
a new investigation well the polls have
been all over the map but if you add up
all the polls that have been done since
it happened by about 2006 the country
was split with about a third of the
people not believing me if it you know
really siding with the 9/11 truthers
about a third of the people strongly
identified with the official story and
about a third of the people are sort of
in the middle yeah once one poll
actually showed that it was I think 80
it was 82 percent think that the
government is not telling the full truth
so it's pretty much it's not like
because someone who's a conspiracy
theorist
he's putting up a plan saying okay this
is how it happened this is what they did
these are just people who are just
saying it doesn't make sense it's not
logical what's going on like building
seven didn't get hit by a plane and now
just people are coming out experts you
know scientists engineers former
presidential candidates people law
people like Paul what Congress was a
Senator Paul West listen Oh Paul
Wellstone what were Paul Wellstone was
murdered in 2002 because he opposed the
Iraq war and allegedly because he wanted
to investigate 9/11 he was a US senator
he was the leading left-leaning Democrat
in the US Senate and his name again is
the Hall Wellstone yeah one week before
he died he was running for re-election
Dick Cheney had personally targeted him
and said you know we are gonna take
Wellstone out of the Senate one way or
another and then one week before he died
well as Cheney threatened Wellstone
saying that if you continue with your
obstructionism there will be the most
severe possible consequences to the
state of Minnesota and to you personally
then one week later wellstones plane was
taken down he his wife and his daughter
all died along with it
his campaign staff they all died in that
plane crash and there's all sorts of
evidence that that plane crash was
taking it happened through an EMF weapon
and for the details you can google the
film Wellstone they killed him that's a
film out there yeah well and there's a
book called American assassination the
strange death of Paul Wellstone written
by two professors for arrows and Jim
Fetzer let me get your reaction to this
so there all kinds of reasons we thought
we were set up to fail we got started
late we had a very short time frame
indeed we had to get it extended we did
not have enough money they were faith
they were afraid we were gonna hang
somebody that we would point the finger
Lee and I write in a book that we think
the Commission in many ways was set up
to fail because we had not enough money
we didn't have enough time we had been
appointed by the most partisan people in
Washington these guys are they were the
ones who are running the Commission well
the investigation
those were the co-chairs Keane and
Hamilton they're the co-chairs of the
9/11 Commission so theoretically they're
in charge but they weren't really in
charge as they said they were grossly
underfunded they had about ten million
dollars or something like that by
contrast I believe it was over 50
million was spent investigating Clinton
and Lewinsky Challenger disaster was a
hundred million or something so yeah
9/11 they give them a tiny fraction of
what should they should have and then
Keenan Hamilton just sort of were the
figureheads but the real work was all
done by a guy named dr. Philip Zelikow
Philip Zelikow was a history professor
from Virginia who's a neocon he's a
close associate of people like
Condoleezza Rice he was appointed by
Bush and Cheney to rewrite American
military strategy so he's a total
insider and he just describes himself as
an expert in the creation and
maintenance of public myths and his
example of that is like Pearl Harbor the
American people have been taught this
myth about how Pearl Harbor was a
surprise attack by the Japanese Pearl
Harbor is what brought the United States
into World War two if before Pearl
Harbor this Japanese that
attack the American people were against
joining World War two but because of
this attack on Pearl Harbor the American
people were stampeded into unanimously
supporting this war and Pearl Harbor
permanently changed the American psyche
before Pearl Harbor Americans were
isolationist since Pearl Harbor
Americans go along with this big empire
trying to rule the world
so zelicah admits that his job is he
creates and maintains public myths like
the myth of the pernicious Japanese
surprise attack on Pearl Harbor so this
is the additionally Zelikow co-wrote an
article with john deutsch in 1998
speculating on what would be the likely
political social and psychological
consequences of a massive Pearl Harbor
style attack on America such as the
destruction of the World Trade Center
what would have happened if the World
Trade Center had been blown up in 1993
says so in that article imagining the
catastrophic event Zelikow is basically
in you know two years before 9/11 he's
envisioning exactly what's going to
happen after 9/11 the end of Liberty
you know stampede to war yeah the idea
the whole thing he predicted it in this
article he published two years before
Allen says all ago I think
wrote the script for 9/11 to co-wrote it
with other people he wrote the script
for what was going to happen
big Muslim attack blame it on bin Laden
they wrote they all wrote that years
before 9/11 and Zelikow the guy who
wrote the script was then made the the
Czar of the 9/11 Commission and he wrote
the entire 9/11 Commission report in
chapter outline before the Commission
even existed and that is admitted in a
New York Times published book by a top
New York New York Times journalist so
the whole thing was a complete a
whitewash and Keenan Hamilton were just
these politicians that they picked to be
the figureheads zelicah wrote the whole
report got at rubber-stamps put it out
there and it was all garbage and the
whole outline of the 9/11 Commission
report was probably written in the late
1990s they kept saying we were set up to
fail yeah Keenan Hamilton knew they were
set up to fail they do they were and I
think the reason they said this was they
realized that history will look back on
this and history will say 9/11 was a
murderous coup d'etat it led to the
murder of twenty thirty million people
around the world it destroyed the
American Empire it put the American
military
into the Middle East where it shouldn't
have been at a time when the real issues
were Russia and China it was a disaster
and history will look back on these guys
and and they're saying hey we were just
set up to fail it's not our fault yeah
someone might say hey Eddie why are you
guys talking about this I say look Joe
Rogan's talking about it so you know the
whole world or our neighbors here think
that Islam is somehow connected with
terrorism Islam you know and that was
the catalyst to go into all these
countries and people are putting slogans
never forget and we're trying to push
back and say hold I never forget Islam
Muslims had nothing to do with 9/11 can
we unequivocally say that well Muslims
were the scapegoats in the patsies the
whole point of 9/11 was to blame Muslims
that's how it was scripted that's how it
was executed that's what it was all
about but Muslims are supposed to be
telling the truth
you know I've you know I've been reading
Quran regularly for a while now and one
thing that really jumps out at me is
that the stories of the prophets all the
prophets they come and they're rejected
by the people of power in distinction
the Milad in whatever society they're in
and they've come with the truth and
they're persecuted for this and
everybody has a choice you can stand up
with the people of truth or you can
stand with the mullah of the fear on the
Pharaoh or you can stand with the Milad
of the the people who persecuted loot
you know the people of Sodom there you
can stand with them a lot of the the
people who you know hamstrung the the
she-camel of the Prophet SAW you can
stand with the bad guys who are standing
against the truth we're kids above a
they deny the truth they'll cry lies to
the truth you have the choice of either
standing with those people or standing
with the voice of prophetic truth that's
so basic to what it means to be a Muslim
and I really implore that all of our
Muslim brothers and sisters you know get
up and and follow the real example of
the prophets when you see in history
examples of things coming out of truth
that you couldn't even fathom you would
think that no way that the
would happen it was uncovered for
instance and this is just to point out
an example that if these things happen
in the past why with something like this
you know when you have experts coming on
to question to who who say that this
just is nonsensical it doesn't make
sense
and you compare it with what we said the
half a billion that was spent on fake
terrorist videos mass deception you know
propaganda manipulating the people's
minds and then the two events that come
to mind the Gulf of Tonkin and North
Woods for people that don't know what
those are you can go look that up and
you can see this is a reality that you
know things were exposed and they're
documented what for what are north woods
and the gulf of tonkin well those both
happened in the same time frame North
Woods was in 1962 the US military
leaders at that time wanted a war with
Cuba and a war with Russia they believed
that they needed to defeat Russia before
Russia developed a robust nuclear
capability so they set up this operation
to provoke a war with Cuba which could
have been extended to Russia
it's called North Woods and they were
going to murder Americans with bombings
in American cities they were going to
sink an American ship they were going to
stage a fake airliner shoot down they
were to load a plane with 200 CIA agents
posing as college students under
carefully developed fake identities and
that plane was in the fly towards Cuba
and then cross paths with an unmanned
drone land at an Air Force Base and the
drone would continue towards Cuba and
then be blown up by remote control
the next day every newspaper in America
would have a screaming front late page
headline evil communists under Fidel
Castro murder 200 innocent American
college students and they so this was
drafted under the authority of General
Lyman Lemnitzer who was the head of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff at the time it was
signed off on by every single member of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff which is the
top of the American military command
chain it was sent to john f kennedy's
desk for his approval and kennedy and or
his Secretary of Defense McNamara
rejected it and that's the only reason
it didn't happen it was ready to go
within a month
as for the Gulf of Tonkin incident
that's what got us into Vietnam all out
it happened in 1964 actually didn't
happen in 64 because there was no such
attack the American media told Americans
that an American ship had been attacked
by the North Vietnamese but it was
garbage it was nonsense there'd been no
such attack and an American ship was set
up to fire some guns into the fog and
say oh we were attacked so that that's
just one of the many many orchestrated
false flags or war trigger events that
have been behind every single major
American war since the Mexican War so
when you bring this up this is
substantiate this is something that you
can't argue right these two incidences
absolutely and most of the others - I
mean nobody today argues that the
supposed Mexican attack on America that
launched the Mexican War of 1847
actually happened everybody missed it
never happened but the newspapers of
that time stampeded America into the war
on Mexico where we stole half Mexico's
territory based on this lie and likewise
nobody thinks that the Spanish really
sunk the USS Maine in 1898 all
historians admit that the Spanish didn't
do that yet the official story of the
time which led America to attack Spain
and steal all of its colonial
possessions was based on this lie and
everybody today all historians admit
that it was a lie so Joe Rogan knows
this he talks about this the Gulf of
Tonkin Northwoods so his position now
with with this 9/11 I know he says he's
had on guests before you've you've even
had Trump who actually questioned then
he also questioned the official story at
one time you try oh yeah 9/11 itself
Trump was asked about it and he said
there had to have been explosives this
couldn't have happened
that's our president now he said and you
know what else he said he said that
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama created
Isis and he was largely right about that
- so how do people like conveniently
you've had so many so many people they
were questioning this official story so
many people that people don't know about
they don't get the media attention
because obviously it's not the cool
thing it's not trending - go ahead and
question the official story which was
set up to fail
they said the commissioners yeah well
you know it's trending among people who
like to think of themselves as actually
paying attention to what's really going
on in the world you know it is trending
among smart people it's a but there's
the problem is that there is this kind
of you know this kind of division
between a lot of the folks who figured
this stuff out they think of ordinary
people as sheeple you know they kind of
look down on them and I think that
really the lesson of 9/11 and similar
events is that ordinary people actually
are okay they have good hearts there is
a human fitrah which is that we will
fight if we are attacked will fight
defensively but we don't really want to
run out and go attack somebody and steal
their stuff and so the psychopathic
leaders have to find a way to brainwash
ordinary people into waging aggressive
war and that's what things like 9/11 the
Gulf of Tonkin incident the Pearl Harbor
eight-point plan that was a deception to
the sinking of the Lusitania that got us
helped get us into World War one
Zimmerman telegram that helped get us
into World War one all of these every
American war has been started with these
kinds of lies and that's because
ordinary people have good hearts and
they can't you can't get them to go off
and wage aggressive war unless you
brainwash them with a big life now you
wouldn't yourself if you thought I mean
you you are an academic you're a
professor at the Wisconsin University
and not anymore
yeah you put your livelihood and
everything on the line but you you would
have not come to the point that you
actually ended up accepting Islam if
Islam was about terrorism violence as
dan Crenshaw tries to make it of course
yeah I got interested in Islam through
the work of the traditionalist scholars
like Rene genome and I got interested in
the Moroccan Sufi tradition in the karo
methyl alia the stories of Moroccan
Sufis that's what my PhD dissertation is
about and I could always see that Islam
had a whole lot in common with
Christianity except it made a lot more
sense to me anyway
I was born in a Unitarian family or we
could call him a family of lapsed
Unitarians which is about his lapsed as
you can get but Unitarians are people of
reason and they believe in the oneness
of God not the Trinity and so that's my
background and so it was pretty easy to
come to Islam and so for me as Islam is
a robust tradition that actually fits
the modern world better than
alternatives because it's it works with
reason I mean the Quran keeps telling us
to use our reason over and over it tells
us to use our reason and it doesn't we
aren't burdened with things like the
Trinity and these other sort of
mystifications that I think cause
problems with Christianity but I mean I
have great respect for my Christian
brothers and sisters I know that people
in the Christian tradition can achieve
sainthood just like people in the
Islamic tradition can and it's crazy
that the world has been brainwashed into
thinking that these religions are
violent that their problems they're
actually more like solutions and this is
important because it's a fact that most
of the time if you do mention Islam to
just an average layman who's been
brainwashed and you know poisoned by the
media deception and manipulation they'll
write away a tribute what to Islam 9/11
yeah it's sad to see this it's
nonsensical usually when you just you
know you're awoke and you start to look
into these facts out there that many of
the things you've mentioned but many
people right away it's like all those
guys in the 911 people who did who want
to come over here and kill us yeah and
they designed it that way of course you
know Philip Zelikow the guy who I not
only wrote the 9/11 Commission report
but as I said I think he probably was
involved in planning 9/11 itself he's a
specialist in public myths so he knows
that these sort of sacred myths are
often founded on human sacrifice and
he's sacrificial events pagan religions
are all based on human sacrifices
so 9/11 was set up ahead of time as a
kind of a mass human sacrifice event to
create this new myth this myth of well
an anti-islamic myth the myth that
we have to go and attack Muslim
countries and that myth has had one main
beneficiary which is the extremist
faction in the State of Israel that
doesn't want to make peace with its
neighbors which are Muslim majority
countries doesn't want to make peace
with its indigenous Palestinian
population which is even though there
plenty of christians it is muslims or
'ti and i do think that's a lot of the
reason for 9/11 Philip Zelikow is a
Zionist the neoconservatives are almost
all Jewish Zionists and those people I
think knew that Israel couldn't continue
on this path of expansionism ethnic
cleansing and supremacism unless they
had the full weight of the American
Empire behind it smashing all of their
enemies and that's I think the primary
reason for 9/11 some people now they
hear you mentioning Jewish and other
things the synonymous with that and they
think all this guy is now promoting
anti-semitism you know he hates Jews and
this myth also that's perpetuated that
islam teaches Muslims to hate Jews what
do you say about that
well obviously Islam is not anti-jewish
yet the Quran retells the stories of the
prophets most of whom are Jewish
prophets in fact if we consider Jesus or
easily sallam as a Edea he was Jewish
too in that sense right so almost the
vast majority of the prophets in the
Quran are Jewish prophets and the
Quranic rendition of their stories
actually elevates them it makes it clear
that they're pure spotless voices of
truth telling God's truth so you know we
see ourselves as being in the same
tradition as Jewish people and if we
actually sit down and talk with
religious Jews as I did recently with a
guy named David who's a very strong
advocate of the Jewish religion we find
we have so much in common with them that
you know a person who is a truly
religious traditional Jew like David
it's going to have a lot in common with
us the people that we have more of a
problem with I think are the post
religious people who you know that
they're no longer really religious Jews
but they have to grasp onto something so
they grasp onto the State of Israel
actually atheist many of them are pagans
eight
it's real was founded by atheists and
they're not religious Orthodox Jews that
we're talking about here right so the
problem is this problem of idolatry that
a lot and this is a problem with
Christians too the Christian Zionists
are also guilty of these this idolatry
of worshipping the State of Israel and
that's really the main problem that we
have with people who consider themselves
Jews and we certainly don't have that
problem with all people who consider
themselves Jews there's Natura Carta a
great anti Zionist Jewish group there
are lots of free thinkers in the Jewish
population some of them are not
religious others are and they're coming
on my radio show all the time telling
the truth standing up for the truth
there's that prophetic voice of truth
can be found among all sorts of people
including lots of Jewish people yeah I
have a good friend Miko pilet you know
have you heard of him he's a general
well he has yeah he's an Israeli he's
Jewish he's somebody who's trying to get
the truth out there regarding the
oppression of the Palestinian people
his father was what his grandfather was
one of the signers of the of the
declaration of independence for Israel
yeah and he's Israeli he's a Jew but
it's an example of someone who's on the
side of getting truth out that's right
also and I'd like to mention that it's
very important that Jews you know
throughout history have always come and
sought refuge in the Muslim lands from
persecution and particularly Christian
persecution if you want to be specific
and Muslims if we hated Jews you would
have they would have a home a refuge to
come you know to come and take refuge in
and Muslims you know the Albanians had a
term besa they'd give the besa you know
their word that they would protect them
and they've been in bosnia and and many
places in in the Muslim world you saw
this it was a David Morris versus team
he wrote the paper the paper and the JC
Journal where it's titled Islam saved
the jury the jurors people so this just
destroys that myth that's right yeah
from you know there were some problems
between Muslims and Jews at the very
early stages and then there have been
the problems relating to Zionism in the
last century but other than that Jews
and Muslims have gotten along pretty
well in particular Jews
found that because we Muslims are bound
to protect people of the book including
Christians as well as Jews and we're
bound to protect religious freedom in
general and try to solve problems
between these groups that get into
conflicts that the Muslim world has
usually been a pretty good place for
Jews and and you know at the time of the
Ottomans there are a lot of Jews who are
fleeing Western Europe for the Ottoman
lands for protection so it's unfortunate
that this Zionist movement has caused so
much havoc in all kin relations between
Jews Christians and Muslims and probably
if if we're gonna solve this problem I
think that Jews Christians and Muslims
need to be sort of central to talking
about how we can get beyond this problem
of tsiyon ism and honestly the the
obvious solution is to have the people
of Palestine all be on an equal footing
and this is one of the solution that the
hardcore Zionist can't accept but I and
today the people of Israel for the most
part are not on board with this but more
and more thoughtful people including
Jewish people all over the world see
that this kind of apartheid supremacist
State of Israel cannot continue for
indefinitely at some point it's going to
have to make peace with its neighbors
and that really means it's going to have
to become a normal country where the
local people including the Palestinian
ethnic cleansing victims have the same
rights as anybody else mm-hmm so we want
people to never forget never forget that
Islam which simply means to acquire
peace by submitting your will to the
will of the one who created you the one
that Jesus submitted to the one that
Moses Abraham they were all those who
were Muslim Muslim simply means one who
submits his or her will to the creator
of the heavens and earth and Islam is
clear that just taking one innocent soul
is as if you killed all of mankind so
this absurdity you know that Islam has
something to do with motivating people
to go ahead and blow up you know
buildings and innocent people this is
just blown out of the water this is it's
nonsensical it doesn't make sense so
never forget Muslims Islam true Muslims
one who would want to achieve that peace
with their crater with humanity do not
want to die with innocent blood on their
hands because that's the first thing
you're going to be accountable for on
the day of judgement in front of your
Creator and if you're Muslim you believe
in the paradise along with believing in
the one and only one creator the pure
monotheism you believe in the Hellfire
and the paradise and we want to stay far
away from the Hellfire so no Muslim is
trying to kill any innocent human being
absolutely and that what's the
definition of terrorism it's
intentionally targeting innocent
civilians for political purposes so no
Muslim can be a terrorist and indeed in
the classical Islamic tradition we're
not allowed to burn crops you know to
burn people's house even if you're at
war and fighting desperately for your
lives and for the lives of your loved
ones you can't do those things you can't
kill innocent people and you know
Muslims more than anyone else have this
although Christian Just War Theory has
something pretty similar so this notion
of religious terrorism Islamic terrorism
is nonsense it's actually the atheist
world that doesn't have any limits
anymore and so they're the ones who are
willing to kill civilians and they're
the ones who are killing the civilians
and each big war kills more civilians
World War one I think it was something
like a third of the casualties were
civilians world war two it was two
thirds maybe three quarters of the
casualties were civilians and it's
expected that if there's World War three
aldo be la it'll be 98 percent of the
casualties will be civilians and and
that's evil and that's wrong and muslims
are in the forefront of people saying
that i hope this gets to god-willing dan
Crenshaw and if anybody's open genuine
sincere you know this is just common
sense it's not nonsense
like he was spewing and hopefully Joe
Rogan who's really toned it down much
respect for that but hopefully he he's
uh he seems like an open-minded person
and I'd love for him to have you on the
show discuss as many of these things I
would too you know I think we talked
about your last time I was here several
years ago and at that point he was he
was saying some pretty crazy things
looks like he's maybe been listening to
you Eddie hopefully yeah hopefully we
can and this is how you can that mean
have a nice healthy dialogue to to bring
on people you know from this side from
you know academics from the Islamic side
and come on and then have a nice whole
open dialogue and this is how you to get
those beliefs
and let's look at the evidence it's hard
finding reasonable people who have you
know once once they get you know this
bitten by the bug of Islamophobia it's
sometimes hard to talk to them you know
I've tried it with a few of them but
there are a lot of people who were sort
of loosely in that camp who are
reasonable people but so and and I like
to think that some of them like there
are a couple of Dutch guys who were in
that Islamophobic party who who actually
come to Islam so maybe some of the most
hardcore crazies like this krenshaw
if they suddenly noticed the truth it
would impact them strongly enough that
who knows where they would end up yeah
there was a just not too long ago
recently a Dutch politician he was the
right hand for Gert wielders you've
heard of him he accepted Islam he was uh
he was comparing he was looking at it
from the point where he was about to
write a book you know a reference book
to all of these different things that
attack that someone can go and look into
it if they wanted to disprove Islam or
have their arguments set so then in his
in his investigation of Islam is is an
Islamic forum he wanted to ban Islam and
from there he started to do his research
and then you know he reached out to
Muslim scholars and from there
he ended up accepting Islam it's amazing
yeah that's been one of the ironical
effects of 9/11 is that a lot of folks
have looked into 9/11 they've looked
into this war on Islam and all the
propaganda against Islam and the
propaganda is so bad it's so divorced
from reality that once they actually
start looking at the reality they
sometimes our impact it's so strongly by
it
that they end up coming to Islam so
there may actually be more people coming
to Islam because of this yeah well I
want to thank you how can people get in
touch with you if you look into some
more of your work I can reach you that
well my website is truth jihad calm as
I'll run together truth jihad and my
email is the same thing truth jihad at
gmail.com Ken can you are you actually I
mean if the people of different
universities wanting to invite you to
speak you know some of the student
associations you can come on and
except those invitations I would be
happy to yeah I've done that back in
2006 and seven I had a lot of
invitations through Student Association
since then not so many and there may be
opposition the Zionist groups really
don't like me so if you're willing to
stand up for the truth and take some
hits from those who don't want at this
point of view to be represented please
I'd be happy to come speak we can get
you god-willing on the Joe Rogan show
and would you be happy to sit across
from Dan Kershaw I have a nice little
dialogue debate absolutely I promise not
to call him and when I do she'll be
promises not to call me a conspiracy
theorist all right thank you so much
okay thank you thank you dr. Wright for
dr. bear for being awesome with us here
okay
thank you and I thank you guys for
tuning in here to the Dean show
subscribe if you haven't already hit the
notification bell and continue to tune
in here to the Dean show we covered a
lot of interesting facts nonfiction but
I want you to go away with remembering
never forget never forget what that
Islam and Muslims had nothing to do with
9/11 because we know what Islam stands
for Islam Islam says is laam Islam says
love all mankind and how you gonna love
all mankind if you're blowing up all
mankind it doesn't make any sense
use your mind your heart and if you're
sincere continue watching the Deen show
and the truth will set you free we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you assalamualaikum